[Applause]
[Music]
hey you're back and that's a good thing
what I need you to do is like follow and
subscribe head ILP and then hit the
little bell icon of this so you can be
notified when new compact talk comes up
or when new flash points come out or
when new ILP information runs that way
you can be notified but in order to get
all the great stuff that we have for you
guys you must hit the like button and
you must subscribe see some Maisie
boxing gym
you go all the main street fighters come
from 100% as you can see there's a lot
of bags full size ring for your limping
training a lot of champions came in and
out of this place
come in and train young and old every
bag imaginable
speed bag heavy bag full body bag full
size ring combat talk with the King so
now we have Daniel Cormier versus Derek
nice
I find this fight to be completely odd
to be honest with you
for me a short notice Derrick Lewis on a
quick turnaround slow to win and Cormier
looked at a bit out of shape look a
little bit touchy you understand like I
don't know Derrick Lewis looks like you
know he's trimming down I think he needs
a different kind of nutritionist to
actually get him into super combat shape
you know because what his problem is a
stamina is cardio that's not home he's
probably on me
actually is well-rounded all-around
great fighter you know the only person
that he did leave soon is Jon bones
Jones and we understand the
circumstances what goes into that I
actually feel Jon bones Jones um it's a
better fighter I actually feel that he
is the kryptonite to Cormier Pommier is
underrated inside fighter under
underrated striker great grappler great
wrestler as a solid base so
fundamentally from that aspect you
understand Derrick Lewis is going in at
a disadvantage he's also going in as a
disadvantage at polonaise a resume his
experience Logan I don't like to see
fighters that are rushed into fights
that they are ready for something rang
out to me when his corner said well when
you're offered a heavyweight fight you
know fighting for the title you know you
got to take it
sometimes what glitters is not gold and
you need to learn to fall back to in
order to seize your opportunity now
maybe it's a perfect storm
maybe comiing not having a full time to
train properly because he's not the most
stealth fighter is you know his physique
isn't sleek and refined core me he's
always presented himself as you know a
pudgy muscular stout fighter so you
won't look to him funny physique
magazines but his conditioning his
conditioning is exactly they're always
at all times he's in fights 100% I don't
think that Derrick Lewis can stretch him
out as far as giving him distance when
he hits when you know he strikes he
doesn't run - and then you bring the
cake over I don't believe that he
stretches him in that fashion and I
don't believe that he has a plus on the
floor so all around I see Derrick as a -
he is an entertaining fighter trust me
when I tell you this he is probably one
of the most entertaining fighters before
and after the fight and during the fight
he's very entertaining as well I believe
that's why the UFC is capitalizing on
him
rather have him lose to somebody with a
stronger pedigree so you can just like
throw that off as well you know he went
up against the best
you know let's put him back in there and
see what happens
I don't see him giving Cormier too much
trouble maybe the first round maybe
maybe the second round I seek or me
getting them tired and wearing them out
in the fight getting stopped probably by
the third definitely about a fourth
round if he makes it to a fifth round
Wow then that would speak volumes of
exactly where he is as a fighter
like I said I don't see him beaten
Colombia at all at this point in time
the only person that could be Cormier as
the guy that keeps beating himself
alright so let's see exactly how it goes
tonight but again my is Connie by
starfish third round four from
completely tops it's combat talk with
the king
[Applause]
[Music]